welcome to this video round 8 of the
open international Bavarian
Championships and we approaching the
final rounds only two rounds left round
ain't that wrong 9 yeah in this game I'm
playing black and I play German
international master Galip mines he's
some veteran Bundesliga player in
Germany and he's rated exactly the same
as I am it's quite funny you really
don't get this very often in an open
tournament that you play someone with
exactly your writing but it happened
here because for the drawing or firm of
pairings they use German rating where
I'm a bit higher but this is a very very
open open game in terms of playing
strengths of the players and we both
were on let me think about it five and a
half out of seven so it was clear for
both of us that one one and a half
points are needed for a prize so I've
got black so my attitude to this game
was play play a game let's see what
happens
losing is bad winning is excellent draw
is okay yeah and I had a look at his
opening repertoires very solid player
but not not passive you know it's just a
very very sound repertoire with deform
and he in fact played deform I actually
expected to get one of my book openings
like the buco on him though but it
didn't happen
he went Knight a 3e six and here he
invested a couple of minutes and then
played Bishop f4 Wow
the London system not the kind of
opening that you see very often on a
higher level but okay sometimes
sometimes people come up with that and
what he definitely a managed was to to
surprise me in a way because I had never
expected such a relatively quiet opening
to be played he normally really plays
main lines so I was really only thinking
about c4 in my preparation and my prep
wasn't super extensive I was just
relying on my general knowledge of those
those kind of openings that I'm
preparing for my book yeah but Bishop f4
afterwards he just said that he was a
little bit tired of his normal lines and
wanted to do something else and it is
really sometimes the case even those
boring lines if both players want to
fight will you get a fight yeah even out
of this quiet lines ok c5 plate III and
here yeah I basically I normally played
b6 here and let's say after something
something like that I set up a head
shock type of position a good line
definitely but some some weeks ago a
friend of mine mentioned that there is
an interesting setup with knight c6
starting with 96 and d5 and i wanted to
try this out takes and not takes a 92
bit should be six yeah this is the setup
looks very very simple but it leads
normally leads to a quite interesting
play um why it's normal reply here is
Bishop to g3 and after castles Bishop d3
black plays b6 and what white normally
does is he plays something like this 95
Bishop e7 f4 after which black plays 97
intending to play Knight f5 this is
quite quite a dynamic position it's not
not boring at all there are all pieces
on the board and black has those ideas
you are using the Knights f5 84 while
White has a good grip on the sand
and then good pieces so this is a tense
position and this is what I was aiming
for when I am said that the board yeah
however he played differently and it's
not like is this any prep he was just
playing chess over the board he took on
d6 if we go back him he captured on d6
not very exciting but we get an
interesting position I can promise you
he Queen takes and Bishop to b5 yeah
Bishop to b5 is simply played to prevent
e5 if he plays something like that
I can play e5 and after that it's over
with any sort of interesting play yeah
Black is even somewhat easier to handle
so this move was expected to should be 5
Bishop to d7 castles castles yeah now he
played a form yeah
a4 is interesting what this move does is
it addresses the idea to play Knight to
form the the point is are threatening
Knight takes d4 if he plays um yeah
let's say nothing moves like this I can
I can take him using this type of tactic
a4 is some addressing this idea yeah now
now black has a number of options I can
also just play the move is a six I I
didn't like it that much this kind of
simplification because I thought that
maybe he gets something with night here
and night to c5 and a5 this kind of
thing it's not very dangerous but I
spotted something else another idea and
I went for this because I thought that
it leads to interesting play
I went ninety-seven of course
interesting play only happens with what
he did he can just take the 7 which just
trades down and is boring but of course
he does not want to do that he played
Bishop b3
don't think with this Bishop f4 move he
played for a draw I just wanted to have
a different kind of position that that
usually that usually plays yeah
my idea was with ninety seven to play
this move and I did this Bishop c6 the
intention is to go Knight e4 and
possible or continue with ninety seven
and then go if I've interesting it was
clear that he wants to go here
ninety-seven and f4 I understand that
this is probably worse for black in
comparison to to this a6 move earlier
like here just go hey six is probably
the better move but I thought that is
this this continuation is interesting
and I didn't mind to have a fight him
okay f4 f6 was played and he went queen
h5 originally I wanted to go h6 year I
need to do something about h7 hanging
him but yeah I wasn't sure if this is so
great so I went at five it's not a huge
difference I cannot do without the move
from anyway in the long run and it's a
structure that I had envisioned before
and anyway
yeah Knight f3 Knight f6 queen h3 and
now I went b6 to make sure that I can
also recapture on c5 with the porn yeah
how to evaluate this position the
structure is wide better maybe a little
bit at first you think that this is
really something serious for what
because he has the better bishop that's
true but don't forget that in terms of
space black is not doing well we have c5
against c3 as black and the somewhat
bad-looking bishop on c6 can sometimes
be activated via e8 and h5 this is
especially true if white continues
aggressively with with the g4 push and
this is in fact
what he did he played g4 this is leading
to very interesting play and I think
also probably wide Sun a best shot and
an advantage
I played 90 for him maybe this isn't
that great but the reason why is it's
very young it's very weird the computer
is now suggesting an interesting line
and as I guess the line that didn't
really popped into both of our minds the
engine in this case Houdini suggests now
to take on C high F which looks really
weird especially because I can recapture
with the pawn but after rook a to D 1
this idea to take on c5 at some point
wide is now threatening to take on e4
and then jump to g5 winning a pawn aha
why okay let's say I made a play move
like that then it takes and goes here
threatening checkmate and if I cover
that he can take on e4 very very
annoying yeah it is really not easy to
play this as black after rook 81 it
seems that I probably should drop back
to f6 and after something like that you
can play rook T to possibly intending
route g2 at some point the computer
gives white some advantage here and yeah
maybe this is true it looks a little bit
strange to take on c5 but I think why
does a little bit easier to play him not
a line that I think we any of us
considered seriously it looks a bit
strange to take on c5 out of the center
he played Queen g2 yeah Queen g2 the
move that looks fairly normal the queen
is not doing much on a3
anyway yeah I took on g4 Knight takes
and Knight f5 yeah note that this is
quite comparable to what I had shown
earlier you know the line that I
described when white plays seven Bishop
g3 those two nights are really nice
pieces they always yeah guaranteed some
counter play one point is that those two
knights both them fulfilling useful role
while White has two knights that really
compete for just one square the e5
square Queen e2 and now I play troop to
c8 yeah this was played to get the rook
on the seventh rank may be using it them
after possible g5 or things like that
he went to e5 and that played now Ruka
c7 and not a bad move probably but I
think an interesting option was a five I
didn't think about it that much
I didn't really think that a five from
White is something that that I should be
concerned about but maybe it was an idea
to simply prevent the prevented after
Luke c7 he went a five and then I
recognized that I probably must play C
for now which is not terrible but
nothing that I definitely wanted to do
beforehand yeah c4 and back to C - yeah
b5 em I have to keep it closed giving
him the F Alyssa is of new use and now
92 was played very logical move the
knight on e4 is is a problem and as
mentioned White has two knights
competing for a five so to trade one is
a good idea yeah and well I can retreat
you have six theoretically speaking but
what is the point really so I just took
on D to clean takes and Bishop yet yeah
I want to get this Bishop into play
what I was thinking is that my king is a
little bit safer here and maybe maybe on
a good day I get and stuff like g5 and
route g7 with an attack must be a very
good day but maybe I get this in yeah he
played Queen e2 now and with this move
offered a draw very interesting moment
in the game um yeah I offered the draw
mostly because he was a little bit low
on time um I had played as usual as
usual I'm quite quickly and had about
about 25 minutes left while he had maybe
12 or 13 minutes left so a little bit
uncomfortable timewise and yeah I pretty
much immediately decided to continue to
play to the tooth - maybe exploit this
slight advantage on the clock + is
somewhat insecure King but it turns out
that the the first moves that I played
with the the move that I played together
with declining the draw was really not
so precise I played Queen e7 the idea is
to go to h4 and prepare Bishop to h5 not
nothing it's not unlogical or illogical
to do that but it seems that right now
after a four which is what he played is
having a slight advantage I probably
should have played something like this
in order to have 97 after the movie 4
and this is probably about equal at
least that this is what the the engine
assesses this position like yeah
complicated yeah very complicated
position and interesting to play
I simply underestimated the e4 most
eform now I have to take 96 does not
make any sense really so I take Bishop
cakes and Queen h4 I was
optimistic here because I have this move
and I thought that maybe also the F for
porn can be a weakness yeah I have a
rook and the Queen playing against it
but um ultimately it's not a big deal
what can easily defend the pawn and he
has good pieces and great Knight only
five a good Bishop only form so here I
already need to be concerned with
keeping an equal position Queen F 2
Queen h6 I don't want to trade King H 1
and Bishop h5 quite logical with a 1 and
yeah here I start to drift enormous leap
jam to be honest I did not really know
what to do here and then I decided to
play waiting like King h8 yeah what I
simply did is I overlooked his reply and
after that King h8 is really a totally
useless move
he played now the very strong move Queen
g2 why is this strong it plans Queen g5
and the Queen trade is excellent for
white because the problem that white has
us is slightly insecure King position
and after Queen trade
this is totally nullified so it's
nothing that I like to see him trading
Queens this really put me yeah
well this really am irritated me the
Queen g5 idea and after some
consideration
I played Knight to d6 but with 96 I
overlooked something I should have
played Queen f6 it seems this I should
have played with white being somewhat
better but nothing too serious after
this however I am in trouble and in
trouble due to a tactical idea which
however was not easy to see and he did
not see it he went Queen g5 just as
planned and this keeps an advantage no
doubt about it but he could have played
f5
which is very difficult to see move for
a human player the reason why is that
after TX he can actually capture here
and the reason is takes takes because
the Queen has this long diagonal and
actually delivers a background check my
tiem if I play this mistaken series of
moves means that after f5 well I can
take probably should take but but here I
cannot take on f5 and this is really
really really bad for like I honestly
have have doubts if I could have kept
this position together I think after a
five this is in fact this is the
relatively best defense route g8 not
very attractive
why just has this fantastic night only
five plus the activity I'm not sure that
it's objectively lost I think the
computer is still claiming 0.9 or
something but in a practical kind of
game mmm I don't know I don't think I
would have been able to save this looks
very very bad but he didn't find the
move we both didn't have much time left
I was catching up rapidly on the clock
noticing that after declining the draw I
basically immediately yeah got caught
into trouble
yeah well he played didn't play this he
played Queen g5 and I was oblivious of
course a5 I didn't see Queen g5 was what
I expected yeah and now I went Roop to
f6 I did not want to allow him to take
on age 6 and spoil instruction so route
f6 you played Bishop c2 this is maybe
slightly inaccurate but it's very
difficult it's a very difficult thing to
to look at those those moves
with the serious time pressure and
criticized them bishop c6 is what the
computer gives and it just seems to be a
little bit more active here it looks at
this pawn and limits the knight a little
bit more than bishop C Tudors after that
what advantages is quite substantial
maybe not a win but it's very
uncomfortable um Bishop c2 was his move
they went a six yeah he now took him
rook takes and their five yeah this type
of position is exactly why King h8 was
such a such a bad idea the position
opens up and I definitely leave my King
to defend the back rank and yeah in
general be a good piece that place so I
went King g8 there is no no big choice
this is also the best defense um
something like the capture here for
example yeah this can easily backfire
and I here widest is just winning
immediately yeah there are some nice
ways to to lose quickly yeah King g8 is
better what I played is better
he took rook takes and now he went rook
f4 rukia form is is not very accurate it
turns out but okay the next couple of
moves um have some mistakes but we both
didn't have much time left
King g2 is better according to the
engine and this is due to the fact that
after you care for I now have a
relatively simple move to equalize the
game and to be honest I'm not really
sure why I didn't play it somehow it did
not occur to me this relatively simple
moves look f6 now equalizes quite easily
the reason is that the position is much
easier to defend as black with just one
pair of rooks than with to my rooks are
not very well coordinate
and exchanging one is helpful and now he
has a hard time to avoid the rule trade
what exactly should he do if he takes
this night does not have any great
square so in fact he has to play
something not very attractive-looking
like yeah look to f1 or something does
this kind of move and well this is
really really nothing nothing for white
after a trade of rooks yeah he has lost
all of his advantage him yeah I did not
play that I played nine f7 one mentioned
as mentioned under time pressure but
still who gave six is fairly simple and
I should have played that yeah now he
went rookie to f1 doubling on the ephah
this was of course the intended idea of
Rubel form Bishop c4 was interesting
maybe a little bit more dangerous in the
time trouble going here's the idea after
95 for example Bishop defiant white wins
straight away I can defend after Bishop
before probably but it would have been
very very uncomfortable in time trouble
rook c2 e7 is the best defence it seems
after Bishop here just rocked e6 keeping
the position to a slight disadvantage
from black not sure ever would have
found that with very little time that's
really the only kind of setup that that
keeps things together and it's still not
comfortable to play yeah he went with
rook to everyone as mentioned here group
each f1 and now it seems that maybe rook
e8 is a little bit more precise but I
went with this move 39 yeah with very
little time left
he played rook air-five now and he had
Bishop f5
was very interesting one point is that
the normal-looking moves rook f6 is
answered by 97 and it's not very
comfortable
it seems that after Bishop f5 I have to
play most like rook to age 6 and after
that White has the dangerous idea
Bishop c8 this looks very shaky AB this
is a checked and there is still this
huge pressure on their farm
it seems that black can somehow keep
things together but it's not not nice or
anything
something like rook back Bishop g4 yeah
and then moves like g5 but white white
is really better young Bishop f5 Bishop
f5 would have been very very problematic
for black I don't think I could have
fooled that I don't know yeah I really
not happy satisfied that I overlooked
the rook f6 resource earlier which would
have equalized rather comfortably
however it shouldn't be yeah we
shouldn't be too critical about those
moves we really didn't have much time
left
rook air-five was played also looks
quite good
and now bishop g6 this was played with 2
seconds on the clock and it was close to
a time loss because I knocked over some
piece and I could just put it back and
press the clock it's 2 seconds left
yeah Bishop g6 ok he took on g6 which is
right and I took with the pawn yeah it
does not look nice the double palm but I
did not want this to happen with the
tempo it looked very uncomfortable
something like let's say root is 6 and
b3
I think what what I played is is better
the the pawn capture
this move yeah and I think around here
probably widest is pointing his
advantage
it is not easy however not at all
he went to f2 I was more expecting the
rook c5 maybe this is the more the more
dangerous way to play white is better
here because he's more active group here
group here and the bishop is always
putting pressure here plus long
long-term there is this issue of the
pawns on light squares where maybe this
Bishop can enter at a later stage my
counter place on the second rank so a
lot without chances but it's it's very
uncomfortable to play he had another
idea he went back to f2 instead instead
of rook c5 he went back to f2 his idea
was to double to double him yeah I
played 96 I need to activate the night I
cannot keep it passive and now I think
on the engine thinks it's very difficult
for human to be so precise yeah that
King g1 is good getting the King into
into the into the game in a way he
played something very logic looking rook
g2 like attacking my my pawn but it
seems that this some and gives up hopes
for an advantage and now I could have
played Knight f5 which would have been
somewhat easier than what I did but what
I played I think was okay as well Knight
f5 um after takes takes rook takes
should lead to a draw
because I'm so active here it's it's
basically impossible for him to to win
this I have a similar idea in the game
just in a more complicated fashion and
if you can keep it simple you should
keep it simple normally I can show you
what I played it's just it just more
complicated
I played rook f7 rook g1 and 95 and here
I'm going for counter play in a
different manner rook takes takes takes
Knight h4 and this is the counter play
rook F 1 is a mate if he is not not
paying attention of course not happening
in a tournament game but of course the
night it's taking away in important
square so this is counter play he went
with rook g4 which is which is right
give it gave the chick root F to Bishop
before yeah and here I played rookie 2
which is again making a little bit more
complicated than necessary it seems that
King F 7 is a little bit better but
rookie 2 is probably enough
the whole point is my rook is on the
second rank and is very very active what
I want to do is I want to have this
counter play against b2 and I have this
Knight f3 rook H to mating idea the
Arabian made my favorite maid I get it
on the board really often let's let's
have a look how this counter play cannot
fold he now played this check on d5
alternatively he could have played
Bishop d7 after which I can take ruk ruk
f1 that's important yeah
after this I'm even better yeah
or winning even meeting wide or winning
material but yes rook f1 and after that
this is the counterplay g5 Bishop takes
g4 intending again Knight f3
Andrew cage to mate Bishop e7 rugae to
a6 like a three very long line but it's
very typical like as activating all his
forces for counter play and this at the
end will lead to a drawn weekend game
you know this in fact would lose to to
look b3 so we will trade those two pawns
and after that basically everybody will
draw so I have enough counter play with
with the activity in the game he didn't
play Bishop d7 as mentioned after Mookie
- he gave this cheque King age 7 and
then rook g4 white can try to win the
game but it is a very risky business and
a decision that an experienced player is
some very reluctant to make he can try
Luke be one covering passively however I
have some substantial counter play g5
for example age 3 king h6
coupe g1 g2 4 takes King g5 and I'm
threatening really to use my king in the
attack white is totally passive and this
is something that a good player really
does not want to have you can easily
easily get to a position where you
somehow lose the b-pawn and then my two
against one here can be dangerous so I'm
not saying that I have winning chance
but this is the kind of here playing for
win when you accept that you might lose
with some inaccurate play and he didn't
have much time left so he decided at the
end after King edge 7 to play rook g4
after which I also
don't have anything else than this
pendulum and here we agree to agree to
draw the game also note that with the
draw me both still were in contention
for a money price in them in the final
round yeah a good fighting game where I
guess I was lucky in the time trouble
faced there were some inaccurate moves
by both sides but it was always some
black being and in danger and I think
with a little bit more time on the clock
a little bit yeah on a good day probably
would've won the game and I know it
looked very very critical for black and
it was maybe a little bit yeah declining
the draw I don't know maybe I should
have just accepted but I like the
position I had more time on the clock so
it it turned out to be a risky decision
but you cannot play draws all the time
and expect to win a price you have to
risk something okay I hope you enjoyed
this game it was an interesting fight
even out of this somewhat conservative
opening thanks for watching